- [Interviewer] Repeat.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Welcome back.
- I'm glad to be here.
- [Interviewer] So, last
time you came in you told me
such incredibly interesting stories.
I'd love to hear more if
you have more to tell.
- Oh Yeah, I mean there's a
lifetime of stories to tell.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, the rumor is
you've got all kinds of great stories.
- (laughing) Well, that's because
I had a lot of great adventures.
And some of them were
actually death defying.
And the other ones were, I
mean were like clockwork.
There's a saying that no great plan
ever survives the first gunshot.
After the first shot is
fired, everything is chaos.
Then it's adjust and
improvise. So, that's life,
adjust and improvise, even
in the middle of a situation.
So, I've been there, done that.
Really. A variety of things
that other people haven't done.
It's like Dante's Inferno.
Nine rings of hell. I've
seen them. Been there.
And not trying to go again
because once is enough,
and it was a tough act to follow.
So, I'll go to a event that
took place in my existence.
It was, now that I look
back on it, you know,
I guess I was out of my rabbit ass mind,
and somewhat coo coo for
cocoa puffs even, you know.
I didn't even know that it
wasn't supposed to be possible.
It wasn't supposed to be
done. But I mean its true.
This was event that
took place off Figueroa.
I call it Figue-whore
because it's supposedly
the longest straight street in the world.
Well, it was at one time, no telling now.
Because it runs from
Exposition without a turn
all the way to Long Beach,
and that's like 26 miles...
I mean all the way to San Pedro,
that's like 26 miles away.
So that's a lot of...
- [Interviewer] Well, I think
they call it Figue-hoe-a
because of all the girls
that are working there.
- Right, 26 miles. From
Jefferson all the way down.
It's the longest straight
street all the way down
to San Pedro.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I talked to about
a dozen girls from there already.
- Yeah, wow. I had pulled up in the car
with a person that at that
time was my significant other.
And when we pulled up, I
was going into the store
to purchase a few things and I asked her,
you know I was asking her what she wanted.
And a guy pushed up on
me. I had the door open
and a guy pushed up on me and he said,
"Say, man, give me a quarter."
And I didn't like the
way he asked. You know.
Because it was more of a
demand, it was like, aggressive.
And so, you know, I looked
at him and told him,
"I don't have a quarter." I
lied. But it was a reaction.
"I don't have a quarter."
And he said, you know
"You's the n-word, you
a mother-fucking liar.
You've got a quarter." I looked at him.
I was like, "Man, you
disrespected my family here."
He said, "Fuck your family."
And my natural reaction was
you know well the talking is over,
so the conversation was
over and I fired on him.
He went back and I was angry at this time
because he was, you know it was more like,
not that he disrespected
her, he disrespected me.
I mean, of course he
disrespect her, but it was more
he did it in my presence
and make me look like
I'm Willy Foofoo or Sammy
Sausage and I wasn't going for it
so I engaged him and I drove him back
because he didn't expect in
that first one when I hit him
you know, kind of had him spinning.
So we went back, about four or five houses
and she jumped out the
car and she was screaming
for me to stop. And I
pushed him back so far
that we ran into a car
and he turned and he ran.
And this time I disengaged, you know,
I was figuring he learned his lesson.
I turned around, I was walking
back. I was still angry
and she was still hollering.
I wasn't really paying
attention to her. And
suddenly he came in you know.
She said, "Look out behind
you" and I turned around
and he was swinging a pick ax.
That's the one that the miners used,
you know to dig, both ends are pointy.
I think it's an eight pound head
and 28 inched from tip to
tip, both tips are pointy.
And it was already in
motion, and I watched it,
I watched it in slow motion. I
watched it go through the air
arch and hit me in the chest.
It hit me in the top part
of my pectoral, it came out
under my arm because it's curved
and it stuck me in the left
arm. And I'm looking at it
and when it hit me you could hear a boom.
And the next thing you
know, I was looking up
and I was down on my knees,
I was down on one knee.
And I looked down at
the pick ax through me
and I seen the shape of the
pick ax pucker through the skin
and I was like, "Man,
I'm dead. Got to be."
I thought it came out my back, you know.
Went straight through the
heart and everything else
like Count Dracula, or somebody.
But it had stuck me in the
arm and I was paralyzed
and I looked up at him
and I tried to stand up
and he pulled it out.
When he pulled it out
blood came with it, lot of it,
like a bucket of blood came out,
that's what it looked like to me.
And so I made it up to my feet,
and now I was trying to disengage
cause I was getting the
shitty end of the stick.
And he swung it side, "Hit
me again, mother fucker,"
and he swung it sideways. I
couldn't utilize my left arm
cause it was paralyzed from the strike
and so I turned my body and I
took the ax handle on the arm
but the pick is so long
that it went around
and went in my back, punctured my lung.
And I felt it. It was
like a balloon popped,
and I couldn't breath, you
know. And all the air just...
So at this time, I moved back
and he went for the third shot
he went for a head shot. And
this time, Dr. Jekyll left
and Mr. Hyde showed up. Mr.
Hyde showed up and saved my ass
a whole bunch of times.
When Dr. Jekyll can't do it
Mr. Hyde can. So I was able
to... the adrenaline surged
I broke the paralysis and I reached up
and I caught the pick ax
while he was swinging it.
It hit me in the palm of the hand.
And I moved it to the
side and I fired on him.
So he went back several
steps and I hit him again.
Now he was dizzy cause I
was giving it all I got,
even though I didn't have a lot left.
So we dropped the pick
ax, and I pushed him back
to a worth iron gate and I took his shirt
and I hung it over the
gate. And he was stuck
like a marionette, trying to get down.
And I backed up and I was looking
and my tennis shoes were
making a sponge sound
they were squishing, cause
they had so much blood in them.
And I backed up, I stepped on the pick ax
and I looked down and I
saw it. Now it's my turn.
So I reached down, picked it up
and I took two giant leaps toward him
and I was fixin', I was
fixin' to stake him out.
But she was hollering, "No,
please don't, please don't."
And I stopped, and this time I was crying
because I was so angry.
And I turned it around
and this is a awkward way to hold it,
but I hit him 63 times.
I worked him off the gate
so many times his shirt tore
and he came off the gate.
And he was crawling, talking about
"Help. Help. Somebody call the police."
I said, "Mother fucker,
you didn't call the police
when you was hitting me.
Now it's my turn. Shut up
and take this." And so I just
beat him across the street.
He was crawling, and I beat
him til he couldn't move.
He was down. And I was just...
I couldn't move my arms no more,
that's the only reason I stopped,
cause my arms felt like lead.
So I threw the pick ax down, and I turned
and I was walking back
to her. And she came up.
She said, "You got bubbles
coming out your back."
I said, "My lung is punctured."
Another dude came out the
house with some towels.
He put one on my back
and put one on my chest.
So, as we went to the car
I said, "Give me the keys."
She said, "You can't drive.
You going to pass out."
I said, "Give me the keys,
man." So she gave me the keys.
When we got to the car I thought about it.
I said, "You know what? On
second thought you better drive."
Gave her the keys cause
she might be right.
So, anyway, she said, "I'm
taking you to the hospital."
I said, "No, you're not." I said, "Take me
to my mom's house." "No, I'm
taking you to the hospital."
I said, "I know what I'm doing.
Take me to my mom's house."
So we headed for the Crenshaw
district. And she's speeding
and running red lights.
I said, "Man, slow down
before you kill not just
me, yourself as well.
So slow down." She said,
"You just passed out."
I said, " No, I didn't. I
heard everything you said."
She asked me, "What did I say?"
And I repeated it verbatim.
So she slowed down somewhat.
We pulled up and I said,
"Okay. I got my alias name.
This is my new name. This
is how we going to do this.
We was over at the mall,
the shopping center.
Some dudes messed with the car. I came up,
and one of them just
hit me with a pick ax.
That's the story we going
to feed to the police
and everybody else when they get there.
So she got out the car
and she ran into the house
to call the ambulance. And I decided
I'm going to get out and go in the house.
As I was walking I seen
them gigantic, bloody,
I wear size 15. So again, I say
gigantic, bloody footprints.
And I was like, "I'm not fixin'
to walk in my mom's house
and leave her with the clean-up.
So I sat down in the hallway
right outside of her door.
My mom came ut crying, "No,
no, not again. Not my son.
Don't take this one."
She was pleading with God
cause she figured I was on death's bed.
So, I told my niece, who
was maintaining my mom,
"Take he back inside." She
she got her off inside.
My girl came back out and she
said, "They're on their way."
So I fed her the story
again. I said, "You got it?
Okay, good." When they came,
when the ambulance came
they asked me what had happened.
You know, I fed the a lie
and they cut my shirt off. I
said, "And he bust my lung."
He said, "How do you know?"
I said, "Because I couldn't breath.
I still have difficulty breathing."
So he cut the shirt off,
he looked at the back,
a nice size hole. I said,
"They also hit me in the arm."
Picked my left arm up and
there it was, a gigantic hole.
So, that was the last thing
I remember until I woke up
and I looked at my girl. She's standing
at the foot of the bed. I said,
"How long I've been here?"
She said, "About four days."
I said, "That's why I'm
hungrier than a mother fucker.
I need something to eat."
And she was like, "Well,
they've got some food
in the vending machine
in tower number two."
I said, "Well, you got a big ass coat on.
Walk your ass over there." I
wasn't really making sense.
I just came out of it.
She said, "All right.
But can I touch you before I leave?"
I said, "Touch me? Why you ask me that?"
She said, "Because the
last time I touched you
you said, Bitch, get you hands off of me."
I said, "They giving me morphine."
Because I had a military
experience where each
time they shot me up,
they shot me up, I engaged.
I engaged the corpsmen,
I engaged the doctor and
everybody else who was around.
So, I knew what they was giving me because
I lived through this before. It had to be,
when I act that way it has
to be that particular drug.
So, she went out and asked the nurse.
And the nurse said, "Yes." She
explained, he goes like this.
This is the reason he was
going off on everybody.
So, they told me they was
going to change the medication,
but it still had to wear
off. She came back in
and told me what had happened. Told me how
they had stitched up some,
left the other ones open
because they didn't want me...
They wanted me to heal
from the inside out.
I mean, I've been through
that a lot of times.
When a wound is so sever they want it
to heal from the inside
instead of closing up.
It might fester inside
and become infected.
So, yeah. When I said I
got hit with a pick ax,
yeah, I got hit with a pick ax.
- [Interviewer] All right,
Repeat. Well, thank you
so much for coming in again.
- Man, I appreciate it. I appreciate it.
- [Interviewer] I'm delighted
to hear that you might
be getting out of here.
- Yeah, the thing is, in 31 years
I didn't have an opportunity or a chance
to hear what I've been through.
And it does something when
you hear for yourself.
When you hear where you
been and what you've done.
And you know it's true because you did it.
It makes a difference. I didn't
talk to the psychiatrist,
the psychoanalyst, nobody in there.
They said I had an anger
problem. I knew that.
I knew that. Still know it.
But I didn't talk to nobody.
I didn't talk to nobody about it because
on that side you gotta
act like a man, you not.
Because a man can talk about it.
That reminds me of we doing now.
And I appreciate you giving
me a forum, an opportunity
- [Interviewer] Now, you're
talking about 100,000 people
or more probably.
- Fantastic. Because it
gives you an opportunity
to understand what's going on.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome. Thank you.